and i would notice over the years no
matter where i was working whatever
market i worked in and whatever station
i worked for there was always that don't
make the sponsors the people paying for
the commercials mad
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former television news journalist and
now candidate for governor of the great
state of arizona carrie lake welcome to
the reuben report hi dave thank you for
having me i'm so excited to be here
carrie i have to start very obviously my
audience is gonna hear former television
journalists they're gonna freak out
because they don't like
journalists am i am i allowed to call
you a former journalist without using
air quotes because you know journalists
these days i think you get it i well i
came up through the old school of
journalism where you you told both sides
of the story if there were three sides
you told all three sides and you kept
your opinions out
and that's why i walked away from my
career i started in journalism 30 years
ago and that's how you did it
and now we've increasingly seen
journalists moving on out being replaced
with propagandists
and i was at the top of my game number
one in ratings for pretty much my entire
time covering arizona most recently 22
years at the fox affiliate
number one that whole time making a
fortune
had a pretty good life and then coveted
struck and i realized there are no good
guys in the corporate media
if there were good guys they would have
covered ivermectin told us about
hydroxychloroquine they would have been
honest about the election and the
corruption involved in that
and i i just you know i looked up in my
career and said oh my gosh i can't do
this anymore i don't want to be part of
this it was getting increasingly more
difficult to be honest with the people
of arizona and if i couldn't speak 100
truth i didn't want to be part of it so
i walked away
i do think there are some good
journalists out there the ones you're
seeing on the corporate media
unfortunately are mainly propagandists
today do you remember a moment that you
started getting an inkling of all that
did it really start with covet or i
suspect in 22 years you probably saw
some other hints leading to where we got
to today
you know the news has increasingly been
moving toward the left obviously over
the past many decades and and i just
always felt like well as long as i keep
what comes out of my mouth and when i'm
being a journalist i can keep that
straight on the straight and narrow and
make sure that i'm being fair i can't
always
be responsible for everybody else that
works in the industry but i know i can
be responsible for myself and i really
truly felt that i could do that for the
most part almost all the time and so
that's what kept me going in my career
you know there's always that that
i guess it would be the law of
television broadcasting and really any
news entity they want to protect their
sponsors and i would notice over the
years no matter where i was working
whatever market i worked in and whatever
station i worked for there was always
that don't make the sponsors the people
paying for the commercials mad for
example if a big
car company in town if there was a
scandal somehow it was always
you know pulling teeth to get management
to want to cover something like that
they would maybe cover it if they had to
but it would be a short 20-second
version of the story rather than
covering it ad nauseam like they would
if it was somebody who wasn't a sponsor
and looking back you you see things like
that and you go wow that's a really
dangerous thing because we saw this
during covet
these news outlets took hundreds of
millions of dollars from fauci
and big pharma and
you almost saw it happening you almost
saw it like this like somebody flipped a
switch and they all started talking so
positively about the vaccines
and there was no critical coverage of it
now i'm not trying to be judgmental on a
vaccine but it is our responsibility as
journalists to put out the truth and not
to tout a product
and not to refuse to cover the dangerous
side effects because the people are
counting on truth from journalism at
least they used to
and so when you see all these tv people
and and newspaper people putting out
only the positives and trying to shame
people into getting shots but not
covering the true side effects and there
are some very dangerous side effects
with these shots i believe they have
blood on their hands and i'm so thankful
that i got out before that business
started up because i was watching that
happen with horror knowing specifically
people who had terrible side effects
and actually blamed uh relatives deaths
on those shots and then sitting there
and watching journalists tout them and
and pump them up like they were the
greatest thing i think it's disgraceful
and hinging on criminal
are you amazed how they can sort of do
it right in front of our eyes i don't
know if you've seen that compilation
that was going viral for a while we've
shown it a couple times on my show where
they show you all the outros to the
commercials the intros and outros to the
commercials on mainstream media cnn cbs
morning news et cetera brought to you by
pfizer the same people who are telling
you how wonderful pfizer is the entire
time i thought at one time we were
supposed to be skeptical about this
stuff
i saw that i saw that compilation at
first i didn't believe it because
sometimes you see these compilations you
go that can't be true but
i was just watching i was uh leaving
north carolina a day ago and i was
watching one of the major networks
morning show and they were talking about
the teen suicide rate and teen mental
illness and all of that and and they did
a whole segment on it and what to look
out for you know they didn't talk about
what caused a lot of it which was these
draconian shutdowns and lockdowns and
quarantines unnecessarily in the masking
of our teenagers which wasn't needed and
caused all kinds of mental problems and
sending them home they didn't talk about
that they just talked about how we've
got teens with a bunch of emotional
issues now and right out of it was an ad
for i forget which big pharma about a
drug for
um depression and suicide and all of
that and i'm like wow it's so obvious
once your eyes are woken up to it but
some people just aren't awake yet dave
some people are not awake there's a lot
of woke people just not a lot of awake
people that that seems to be the problem
uh you did an event about two weeks ago
here in florida i was going to try to
get there and then something popped up
but you were at mar-a-lago with a
certain orange man who will play a
10-second we'll play a quick 10-second
clip here's what he had to say about you
but i will say that i think that's going
to be one of the great things that i've
done endorsing a woman and helping her
get elected i think she'll go down as
the greatest governor
[Applause]
all right so it looks like you've got or
not looks like you've got the
endorsement of trump you've done events
with him um
how does that feel relative to getting
into politics for the first time and
just the general state of craziness and
the circus that is our political machine
well that sound bite that you just
played was just um
it felt really good to hear that because
i i do plan on being the best governor
best governor arizona's ever seen i'll
probably be the first governor arizona's
ever seen that truly was in it for the
right reasons to represent the great
people of this state so when he said
he's gonna one of his greatest
accomplishments will be to help get me
elected and and he knows i'll become the
greatest one of the greatest governors
in the country um that made me feel
really good because i'm in this for the
right reason i trust me there's no
reason you'd want to get into the
corrupt world of the swampy politics
unless you're doing it for the right
reason i i'm not in it for the fame
there's no money in it if you're an
honest person and you're not trying to
you know build the taxpayers out of
their money
i'm just doing this because i love
arizona and i looked at the field of
people who was running dave
and i believe this is the last election
in this country if we don't get it right
and we don't get some america first
people in there running some honest
citizen politicians i don't know that
we'll have a country beyond this
election so i looked at the field of who
was running and it's the typical rhino a
career politician somebody who's run
before lost 20 years ago we have
somebody who's run before
and run against katie hobbs who's going
to be the democrat socialist that we end
up running against and he already lost
to her a few years ago so i looked at
the field of republicans running and i
said not a single one of them can get us
past the finish line and if we lose this
election and we get a katie hobbs who is
a socialist democrat we will lose
arizona and we cannot as a country
afford to lose another border state
we've already we'll be stuck with just
texas holding the line for us and we
need to get strong governors
in these border states to hold the line
for america we are about to lose our
country if we don't have fair elections
and honest elections and we don't have a
border then we do not have a country so
this race is critical and that's why i'm
in it
so i want to jump back to the border
stuff in just a sec but can you talk a
little bit about what generally is going
on in arizona i think most people think
of arizona and they're like no no it
should be a red state it seems like it's
a red state but it doesn't fully seem to
be a red state it really as you're
saying could go either way it's a little
hard to understand what the electorate
is is really made up of there or where
they're really going well let me tell
you arizona is as red as my shirt okay
it's a red state
but when we have corrupt elections that
are stolen
where we have uh mail-in ballots being
sent out to people who don't even live
here and filled out and sent in and we
have ballot trafficking and we have
more voters than even registered voters
voting
then we're going to have a corrupt
election that makes it look like we
aren't a red state and that's why it is
imperative
that we get to the bottom of this
election and we do not allow another
election to be stolen it's not about
republican democrat independent it's
about having honest elections and saving
our country so we're a red state
absolutely we have a lot of people
coming over from california believe it
or not a lot of them are conservatives
who are fleeing they're political
refugees coming in from oregon and and
washington california and other blue
states and of course we do have some
coming in who are bringing their liberal
ideology with them and we're really not
interested in becoming california so
we are a very conservative state a wild
west state and we've got
issue with our border that does not
remain here in arizona when we have
people flowing across people being
trafficked drugs being trafficked they
move to other states beyond arizona i
was just in north carolina for the trump
rally and the good people of north
carolina i think their number one issue
is the border they were chanting build
the wall finish the wall in north
carolina think how far they are from the
border
this is a
an issue that is an american issue not
just an arizona issue and we've got to
get a strong governor in who is going to
finish the wall send troops to the
border and secure our border for the
rest of the country as well
how did this happen with the border do
you think i mean we've been covering
this a lot and reading off the numbers
and it's gotten significantly worse
under biden obviously but what happened
in arizona and texas that allowed so
much of this that allowed so many people
to come in and not just come in but they
come in illegally and then they're
shipped to other states i don't know if
you've seen but my governor here in
florida desantis any any illegals that
they ship here he's shipping them to
delaware i highly recommend i highly
recommend you institute a policy like
that uh once you're governor but what
what do you think happened in arizona
that led to this well i have a better
idea we're not letting in in the first
place we're going to keep them from
coming in and we're going to find them
when they're here we're going to send
them back across the border that way our
tax money's not going to pay for them
what happened was joe biden
and what happened before that was a
corrupt election that got joe biden into
office
and joe biden came in and on day one
he stripped back a border policy that
was the most effective border policy
i've ever seen in my 27 plus years of
arizona i covered arizona for 27 years i
covered the border for men all of those
years and we never saw it better than
when president trump was in charge he
had secured our border the best i'd ever
seen it and on day one joe biden came
and tore that back
completely exposed us to a criminal
element handed over control of our
border to narco terrorists and they
immediately
started to bring in people from all over
the world not just mexico and central
america people from 160 countries are
pouring in coming up through our
southern border and joe biden's pretty
much giving them citizenship by what
he's done and it's going to stop when
i'm governor we are going to shut it
down
we're going to finish the wall and we're
you know have you seen the video of of
all of that material that we've already
paid for i was just down there and
it's outrageous i was down there in
southern arizona walking next to it it
goes on for a mile it's stacked up
probably 20 feet high and it's just
materials for building the wall sitting
there in the desert we're going to take
that back under my border plan we're
going to redefine what it means to have
abandoned federal property and we're
going to use that to finish the wall we
paid for it
we paid for that material and we're also
going to send our arizona national
guard down to the border we're going to
arm them because we're not going to put
them up against these cartel members
without arming them and we're going to
have them
push people back and not allow people to
come across our border if we catch them
we arrest them for trespassing detain
them process them and send them back
across the border and we do have the
right to do that we're going to ask
other states who are interested
like-minded states to chip in and help
maybe they send their state guard down
and we will use them and utilize them at
the border to make sure we have enough
manpower on the border our constitution
allows for this dave
the constitution article 4 section 4 the
guarantee clause it requires the federal
government protect us from invasion and
when they fail to do that in article 1
section 10 clause 3
the states have the power
to take control it's almost state war
power to take control of their troops
and stop the invasion which we intend to
do beginning on day one of my
administration
do you sense that that's kind of the
future of america and not just talking
about borders but in general that will
return to some level of federalism that
we were intended to where the state that
you live in in some ways will be more
important than the federal government i
mean that's really the way the whole
thing was set up it doesn't seem to be
the way we we think we're supposed to be
governed but i sense that coming back i
can tell you from living in california
for the last eight years to where i live
in florida right now it is it is like
living in a completely different country
and i'm actually okay with that
we're going to learn the weak states
versus the strong states you can call
the blue states versus the red states
and i agree with you i mean we realized
during covet just how strong the states
were
we we've handed over way too much power
by the way to the federal government so
it's about time we bring that power back
to the states but we learned when our
governors
exerted their power against the people
during covet how much power they had
unfortunately they used that power
to torture us to shut our businesses
down to shut our churches down to send
our schools um closing and sending our
kids home
they forced our kids to mask up they
forced people to get shots against their
will so they use that power in the most
devious way in my opinion i plan to use
that power to strengthen arizona protect
arizona and give the power back to the
people and and you can see it as as
broad as daylight when you go to a
florida when you go to a red state when
you go to a state like california where
these
terrible uh radical leftist policies
have been in play for 40 plus years in
california they've completely destroyed
what used to be a once great state and
so i believe going back to state power
is the way to go to go back to our
sovereignty we created the federal
government
they didn't create us and we are
sovereign not serfs of the federal
government
what do your opponents say what like
when you're talking to the democrats or
if they're just talking about you maybe
they're not talking to you i mean what
are they saying on the border that i
mean is any are they saying anything
that resonates with people or that makes
sense like what is what is the policy
of a border state democrat at this point
well i'm actually impressed with um that
we're leading the charge my campaign is
i've been on day one talking about the
border calling it an invasion calling it
what it is and now my republican
opponents are now jumping and even
stealing parts of my plan which is fine
because my plan is the best plan out
there for securing the border so i'm
actually pushing the the just the entire
discussion on what we need to do across
the country even i've had other people
reach out to me and say can i take a
look at your plan we might want to
implement it here i have sent it over to
our current governor doug ducey and said
please implement this immediately we
can't wait until i'm voted into office
we can't wait until january 23 we need
to start this right away
he never responded to that i hope if
he's listening that he will take a look
at it and implement it immediately it's
the only way we can protect the good
people of arizona and of america
the democrats of course are open borders
i mean they they love what's going on
they think that we should be bringing
everybody in and taking on the world's
problems and that is why it is so
critical i think arizona is the most
important state the most important
governor's race in the country because
we cannot afford
to lose another red state
to these radicals on the left and i
don't even want to call them democrats
anymore because the democrat party from
you know the jfk era
is completely gone this is marxism
socialism and they have every intention
dave of if they were to get into office
completely seeding the border to the uh
narco terrorists and cartels and i
cringed to think what would happen we'd
have to all rent u-hauls and escape
arizona
i used to think they were just inept and
now i'm i'm with you i think it's
intentional um you mentioned america
first and that is the the sort of the
trump movement motto and i think trump
is obviously uh trying to figure out
where he fits into that with his
political future perhaps you know
something that uh people would like to
know um but what does america first mean
to you i can sense on the border side
but what does it mean broadly it means
putting the citizens of this great
country first and and you know that
sounds like people go well we do that no
we haven't been doing that for a full
generation the political elite have sold
out america they sold out our our
companies our manufacturing overseas
sent it to china they sold and when they
did that by the way they started the
destruction of the america family you
know i i grew up in in many in the 70s
and 80s in the midwest in iowa
at one point during the 80s i remember
almost all of my friends fathers got
laid off they worked in in manufacturing
and plants and and all of those plants
got shut down and they started to move
overseas and that started the
destruction of the american family
because when your dad loses a good
paying job and all of a sudden he can't
find work and it leads to substance
abuse and all kinds of issues it leads
to
just the uh i believe the disintegration
of of the american family and our
communities and so we've been being sold
out for a long time by our political
elite i don't know why they did it if
they were just trying to help
the next quarterly report for the
corporations or if they got there was
something in it for them
but we've been sold out by our political
leaders and finally when president trump
came in we saw what america first
movement was it was about returning
business to america reassuring
manufacturing
putting the needs of our american
citizens first
and i believe that is the only way out
of the mess we're in restoring our
freedoms to americans during cobid we
watched as people gave away their
freedoms
and we you know we we watched as people
said okay i'll mask up okay i'll get the
shot okay i'll do that every single time
we give away a freedom we've got to
fight to get it back
and we're at a point where we're
standing up and fighting and we're going
to take it back we're at the 11th hour
to save this country and if we do not
stand up and speak out and risk being
canceled and persecuted who cares if
they if they call you names we got to
stand up and and fight to take our
freedoms back and and push these
marxists
to the to the edges and tell them we
don't want them anymore they're not
going to be controlling our kids
curriculum they're not going to be
controlling our businesses anymore and
shutting them down
we have to bring america first policies
back and save this country
how nasty do you think that fight
between the america first crew and sort
of the the rhino crew or the swamp crew
or the traditional republican crew is
going to get because i spend most of my
time on this show trying to expose the
woke thing to people and have people
wake up and say hey we can set aside
some of those differences on the right
and figure some of that stuff out but
you can feel a fight really brewing
there between the america first thing
and whatever you want to call it the
rhino swamp thing whatever it is
especially in arizona there's a there's
remnants of the kind of the mccain camp
here still which is really rhino and uh
we have rhinos like jeff flake and all
of that so we
we have a pretty big swamp here in
arizona and they're on their last gasps
of air but they are fighting the devil
doesn't go down easy
he he fights back and and so i'm really
feeling it i mean they're running attack
ads on me they've been doing so since um
august when i jumped they realized when
i jumped in the race
that i was a force to be contended with
and that i was soaring in the polls they
have poured millions of dollars into
this race to try to bring me down and
this is the swamp this is the swamp not
just from arizona i found out that one
of the guys sitting on the super pac
running ads against me is a rhino from
michigan who most likely may have been
involved in that fraudulent election up
there they're scared to death to have a
trump republican who is
bound and determined to bring justice
for our corrupt election in 2020 we're
not going to let people walk
if they defrauded the voters of arizona
we find out who they are they will be
held accountable and they don't want
someone like me in office so it's going
to be a knock down drag out fight but
i've got um you know i've got a message
for them i am a fighter
and when i set my sights on something i
make it happen and i'm not afraid to be
called names i'm not afraid for them to
attack me
i i i'm gonna stand tall for arizona and
stand strong for arizona and i don't
care what they say about me we're gonna
win this and we're going to get arizona
back on track and the days of the rhinos
and the swamp are done
now i'm not saying i won't work with an
establishment republican if if they want
to come together and work with the
america first movement and and be all
about making arizona the greatest state
in the country then i'm all for it i
want to bring people together i want to
bring even democrats who are waking up
to the insanity
of the left and this you know fringe
group on the left who are trying to drag
this country down those people who are
waking up i want them on our team as
well
we need to grow this conservative
movement this america first movement and
just finally do right by the people of
the state
you mentioned election integrity a
couple of times and fraudulent election
i think you said you know it's funny i
had blake masterzon who as you know is
running for senate as a republican in
arizona and he mentioned it as well and
it's you know most people are afraid to
talk about it or don't want to talk
about it i suppose youtube could blow up
my channel just because you put those
two words together right then and there
don't worry i got some backups i'll be
okay okay um but but what is going on in
arizona in terms of securing the
election that or what or what were the
things i suppose that really set off the
bells the alarms for you and has
anything been fixed and i asked that
because the two candidates that i've had
from arizona have both brought it up
well we're not perfect yet we're not
there for 22 no way
i've been involved i've thrown myself
into a arizona supreme court case which
unfortunately the court decided not to
take up
i'm i'm willing to
risk everything to make sure our
elections are honest some of the people
in politics said oh don't get involved
in that because you're trying to get rid
of mail-in ballots and mail-in voting is
very popular and i said i'm not trying
to do the popular thing i'm trying to do
the right thing and so i jumped into
that case unfortunately the arizona
supreme court didn't have the courage to
take that up i'm getting involved in an
injunction
that uh we're going to ask for an
emergency injunction against these
corrupt
voting machines
and um i'm not afraid to jump into this
fight this is a fight worth taking this
is a hill worth dying on because if we
don't have secure elections we can't
accomplish anything we can't make sure
our kids curriculum is secure we can't
make sure our border is secure if
they're installing people into office
and we're not getting the people we
actually vote for then we've lost our
country so um we did get some
legislation passed that is going to
require you to show proof of citizenship
basically an id
and a social security card right now we
had 16 000 people on our voter rolls who
had no uh driver's license and no
last four digits of their social
security that is an indication they were
probably illegal voters
and there were 16 000 of them on the
voter rolls as you know joe biden only
allegedly won
by just over 10 000 votes so that's the
margin of you know victory i guess you
could say
we have a ton of problems we've had
millions of election files deleted
we have election and state laws that
were broken we have 740 000 ballots that
had no chain of custody those should be
voided out ballots if there's no chain
of custody they need to be voided out
and they were counted
president trump i believe won arizona by
a landslide and i'm not trying to be the
typical politician who always says the
things that the consultants want you to
say
i'm not doing that i am saying what is
true
and i was talking to president trump he
was kind of chuckling he said i love you
you never backed down from a fight and
you could ask carrie what the weather's
like and she'll somehow find a way to
talk about the stolen election in
arizona
but we have to do that because stolen
elections have consequences and all of
the troubles we're facing in this
country dave
stem from that corrupt rigged election
are you worried that a certain set of
people just don't want to talk about it
or i guess more so are just afraid to
talk about it because they don't want
channels deleted they don't want to get
banned from twitter and facebook and
everything else that as righteous as you
may believe it is that it's just like
one of those things where people are
just like ah we got to move on something
like that
we can't move on i mean i wish i wish it
were that easy honest to god i wish we
could say that but we can't
it's if if we do move on that next
election will be the last election it'll
be rigged and then the next one rigged
and there we go we're not a country
anymore
um so we can't move on but that being
said
we're going to do everything we can and
we're going to fight to make it right
we're going to fight to make it honest
so i i'm not worried about being
censored i have been censored before i
think more information is going to
continue to come out i mean we were in
mar-a-lago and we saw the movie rigged
which um dave bossie put together with
citizens united really important movie
talking about the zuckerberg money that
was poured in
you know we
we can't have that we can't have a
billionaire a tech tyrant pouring in
almost half a billion dollars to get joe
biden elected
this is wrong this needs to be outlawed
that kind of that kind of money being
poured in to for one candidate basically
and we're about to see the 2000 mules
come out dinesh d'souza's movie and i
think that's going to be a real
eye-opener for the people of this
country
and if we can just get some honest
elections in there and get some people
who want to get in and make sure that we
get the laws in place to make sure every
election going forward is honest
then we're going to have uh i think
great policies moving forward and we'll
have great elected officials not these
lifelong losers who we have in office
right now
are you telling me that the 450 million
that zuckerberg spent wasn't just to be
nice that he might have had a intention
with that money
yeah that's exactly what i'm telling you
he wasn't trying to help president trump
let me put it that way not neither were
the folks in the media who ran just
attack piece hit piece after hit piece
on trump and refused to cover joe
biden's or i should say
his son's laptop from hell
um it's just been non-stop and you know
that's really where it first started for
me in the in the in the media i started
to see
my my colleagues and all of the media
start to lose their mind when president
trump came on the scene
and that's when i realized wow
there is a serious seriously biased
people here who are trying to destroy
this president who is a transformative
president trying to help can you talk
about some of the energy around that
because i went to a trump rally by
accident i actually happened to pass a
trump rally in beverly hills right by
rodeo drive pretty woman rodeo drive in
the summer of 2020. i i wasn't publicly
supporting trump at that time i was kind
of going in that direction but i had
never seen it but i go to one of these
rallies he wasn't there it was just the
beverly hills trump rally and i saw what
was the happiest most joyous
music dancing american flags everywhere
truly diverse in the right sense of
diverse thing i had ever seen before and
that was one of the things that finally
sort of got me over the hump related to
trump you've been in there in the middle
of it with the energy and all that can
you talk about just what that thing is
like it is amazing it is such a
beautiful show of patriotism and love
for america
of course everyone at those events loves
president trump he's the reason they're
there but
you're watching people i was just in
north carolina at the most recent trump
rally you watch people show up early
it's not easy to get to these places
sometimes they're in out of the way
towns and
they drive a long time to get there they
park a long way back they walk they're
there for hours i'm talking seven eight
nine hours sometimes it's cold this
isn't just a light level of commitment
to president trump this is a deep deep
commitment and love for a man who put
them first who put working-class
americans first who put our families
first
who put our rights first so this is a
deep love and if people think that the
trump movement is gone
they've got their head buried in the
sand it is alive and well and it is
growing by the day
i actually get i almost get a little
emotional when i get to these sometimes
because i look out at the sea of
americans who who love america
and you know doesn't matter what color
their skin is doesn't matter what their
religion is doesn't matter where they
came from they might be immigrants they
might have parents who are immigrants
they might be
seventh generation americans
and they're there because the thing that
binds us together
is is that common thread that we love
america and that's why the left and the
radicals on the left are trying to
destroy that and make patriotism
and they're trying to make love for
america a bad thing they're trying to
brainwash our kids into hating america
through the through the perverted
history they're teaching what you see at
a trump rally is just pure love for this
beautiful country that we have to save
it's the most
amazing country in the world
and we can't let it go and i i just love
that i'm watching this movement grow and
that people are waking up
you talk about uh history what would you
do on the education side because
obviously so much of this is related to
education we're watching kids be
either intentionally indoctrinated at
public schools or intentionally
indoctrinated by you know woe
corporations like disney uh what would
you do on the schooling side oh well
we're about to put out our education
plan but i can tell you right now first
of all i signed the hillsdale 1776
pledge that's the kind of education we
should be teaching our kids
not this woke garbage and i have two
children one graduated last year from
high school i've got one who's still in
high school so as a parent as a mom i'm
deeply concerned about the curriculum
that's being taught
and i i think really one of the ways to
solve that one of the simplest ways and
president trump has talked about this is
you fund the student not the school
so it puts power back into the hands of
the family gives the family power over
where they want to send their kids and
if if you find out that you're sending
your son and your daughter down to the
local you know the school down the block
and they they're teaching crt and
they're teaching your kids to hate
america and they're teaching your kids
to question their gender you can say no
no no no we're pulling our kids out and
we're going to bring them to this school
and the money follows your child and
when that happens i will tell you in a
very short order these schools mainly
the government-run schools are going to
shape up they're going to realize
they're losing enrollment and they're on
the verge of extinction if they don't
shape up and teach our kids curriculum
that actually makes sense teaches them
to be prepared for the real world it's
called competition right if all of a
sudden the kids are all leaving your
school going to another school
you're going to have to make some
adjustments or you're going to go under
do you think they're too damaged to turn
around so you do that i'm with you on
the the school that you fund students
instead of systems for sure more private
schools more charter schools et cetera
et cetera do you think there's any
chance even if they saw a massive drop
in enrollment that
the public schools would have some value
or could come back well if they don't
they'll go the way of the dinosaur
i mean
if pretty soon nobody wants to come to
your school you're it's going to be
pretty hard it's going to be pretty hard
to stick around i'm a big proponent of
homeschooling i think we need to support
our homeschool families they've been
kind of left out of the equation i'm on
the campaign trail i'll tell you what
homeschooling is growing it's growing at
a very rapid clip because people were
tired of having their kids you know
school shut down and then when they went
back to school they had to you know
abuse the children with these masks so
i'm a big proponent of homeschooling i
think we need to support them as well
but we we need to get really serious
about the curriculum my plan calls for
at 10th grade after 10th grade we put
our kids on a track a career track
whether they're going to go to a
four-year college a vocational school
whether they want to get a trade
skills learned and we can have our kids
graduating at age 18 from senior as
senior in high school with a plan for
a job i was just at a school down in
vail
which is down in a tucson area
and they have a welding program they
started at their school and these kids
are being hired before they even
graduate high school obviously they're
finishing high school but these
companies are coming in offering them 70
to 80 plus
70 to 80 000 or more to take on welding
jobs they're learning that skill in high
school
they get full benefits they can actually
raise a family someday with that kind of
a salary we need people in the trades
really badly and those are the skills
that i think our boys want to do even
our girls want to do those but i look at
sometimes the way we educate our boys
and i'm a mom to a boy
and i know sometimes he would rather be
in a class where he's learning how to
weld or he's learning
some sort of a trade skill and it his
mind and his hands are being worked
then sitting there listening to a
lecture especially if a teacher's
droning on about crt or or you know
switching genders we got to get our kids
ready for the real world
boys like thing girls usually like
people it's just it's reality it just it
just is what it is
um
we got a couple couple minutes left so i
want to i just want to get a couple more
in somewhat quickly so okay we fix uh
the some of the border stuff we fixed
some of the school stuff so now let's
say you're governor it's february march
2023
and uh fouchy calls you and says
time to mask everybody up again time to
shut it down again time to socially
distance again how's that call going to
go i don't think he'll call me i mean i
was the one at the trump rally when i
spoke that so we need to lock that guy
up
frankly we should i mean he's lied if
you've read robert f kennedy junior's
book on fouch i think i have it sitting
right here behind me we've got it here
it's called the real anthony fauci here
right here
i'm not being paid to pitch this but
every journalist in america should be
digging through that and doing stories
on this man he has been more harmful to
our health the health of this country
than probably anybody and and frankly
i'm this is not hyperbole i think the
man should be locked up and charged for
what he did during coven the lies the
lies he lied to congress he lied to the
american people
and i would love to see him and facing
the music for that and and maybe a you
know an arrest warrant out for him
hopefully maybe in arizona we can do
that and then he won't want to take a
road trip through arizona and stop at a
pit stop for a bathroom we might we
might haul him in so we're not going to
do it as in arizona we're not shutting
this state down i want to make it
perfectly clear as governor of arizona i
will never shut a business down
over cobit i will never shut your
churches down i will never ch shut the
schools down over cobid and i will never
mask our children again over covet and
we're going to get it to a point where
people aren't losing their jobs because
they refuse to get one of these jobs
that fauci has been probably making a
fortune off of
so we need to get things set straight
for the good hard-working people of this
country and we are not going to be
taking a cue from
anthony fauci
no way not in arizona
terry i actually don't think we can end
an interview any stronger than that i
think uh
you're not messing around with that guy
let me just say
dr fauci don't call me
you don't want to have that phone call
it's not going to go well for you
fair enough fair enough well listen i am
about to embark on a book tour i am
going to be in your fair state at the
tempe
improv what's the date on that one guys
around may
15 16 something like that we're going to
send you an invite and if you could
may 16th i'm at the tempe improv and if
you're in town and you want to come on
stage and talk to the people i'd love to
have you so thank you i thank you for
doing this and uh good luck
thank you dave thanks so much appreciate
it if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell